[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
where we talk about whatever we want
we have Dom here today what's going on
aka Jim Jesus
okay Dom is Etienne K the professor
thank you for having me very welcome
thanks for coming thanks for coming by
no problem guys so this is the first
time we ever had like a fitness expert
on the show okay so I guess like if we
have any do you have any Fitness advice
you'd like to give any of us do I have
all the advice so it just depends on
what you're looking for so David he just
lost a lot of weight you sorry for your
loss real moment maybe moment a thing
okay that's enough so he lost a lotta
weight and then recently he's trying to
get back into it he's been doing this
Food Show he's been eating all his food
and I kind of getting the calories back
okay so he's having a hard time finding
the dedication to get back in and lose
that additional 10 15 pounds you have
any thought you want to lose weight I'm
trying to lose another 20 smaller you
want to get smaller yeah you're thinking
about it all wrong okay okay think about
it like this I know it's kind of
complicated right get bigger why would
you want to be smaller all right you you
at you're eating food right that's
calories take it in use it that's energy
man just get bigger so what's like that
everyday workout thing I could be doing
then work out everyday pretty simple
it's not it's it's not rocket science
it's bro science okay but it's also
rocket science cuz it's really [ __ ]
complicated okay I think that's the best
advice I've ever heard that's the only
advice I've ever heard that make sense
what every day
yeah why do you want to get smaller
fitness gurus to be feeding you stuff
right because they want to make money
they want it's like they want to keep
you in this system right I just want you
to get big and be your biggest self
whatever that looks like it's not my
body okay you have the potential to get
big - so would you say you kind of
messed up cuz you started off a like 260
something and now he's like
ten now yeah yeah you messed up to sixty
this big wait I was 260 pounds yeah and
that I that I lost it all could have
been 300 what is it is there a
difference in big no cuz there's like
fat big and then there's buff big it
just depends on what you say if you fat
big you say you're a power lifter it's
good it's very simple that's true if you
buff big then you just bodybuilder yeah
I guess you could say that you don't
really have to explain it when you're
that big you know if you're like 260 and
jacked you don't really have to answer
too many questions it's pretty obvious
what you're doing but if you can't you
know like oh I'm just I'm on a bulk
right now is where you could say to if
your body building you're not too strong
let's say and you're like you know maybe
self-conscious that you're not so cut
but you're kind of big just say I'm on a
bulk right now maybe you're never gonna
cut doesn't matter
not the [ __ ] business jersey the
great state capital o born and raised
born and raised
what part of Jersey that's a big
question mark I wish I could answer the
Hat Sergey knows that's a silly question
oh whoops I thought at first he said
patch the g-men and I was like what kind
of a question is that
gee man all the way well it's Joey
Atlantic City that's Jersey or New
Jersey right yeah yeah we'll do one yeah
where do we go where we went to Rutgers
was that Jersey Matty's juice right we
went to Rutgers we talked we spoke out
there but that's not like Jersey City
right no Jersey City's just a city in
Jersey it's kind of confusing I know
yeah yeah but people call it what the
city or they call it they just call it
Jersey City listen I mean Jersey's are
great it's a great state we got a lot
there we got me you know we got Bruce
Springsteen the boss okay but other than
that you have Atlantic City the Jersey
Shore and cows okay for the milk yeah
but no one really knows what's going on
in Jersey City in Jersey The Sopranos
yeah it's mafia and then you live out
here now I do
yeah I've been imported by the
entertainment industry it's great the
Sun shines the girls with basically
nothing and you can Day drink pretty
much any
any time of a week any time of the day
and no one's gonna look at you weird cuz
no one really has a job here so that's
true everyone's on vacation here yep
permanently
mentally you got any questions for us
yeah where are we so we're in this city
called Monterey Park okay it's on the
east side of Los Angeles okay east east
of downtown south of Alhambra no idea
when he that is I wasn't sure if it was
the glasses cuz the kind of yellow but I
thought that might have been like a
Jamaican flag and I was just trying to
get my bearings here um I thought Bach
one that's your name right yeah yeah so
you wanna you to make it right
to make in Chinese okay yeah cuz I was
yeah okay [ __ ] ton of Chinese people in
Jamaica oh yeah dude they have they have
Jamaican access that's what I'm saying
man yeah yeah they have Chinese Jamaican
accent they're like they've been there
for several generations I want to see
hit yeah here I feel like I'm seeing her
right now right yeah they speak like wah
wah cuz I came prepared for an entirely
different show to be honest but thank
god this panned out what show are you
prepared for awesome Jamaican show I
thought we were gonna get high and I
don't know throught the time whatever
sounds kind of fun actually
dude that would be a pretty fun [ __ ]
kidding Rasta time but but we'd have to
smoke we don't exactly it was kind of a
pampering I didn't watch a bunch of guys
though they got stoned and they were
doing a reaction video to our show
what yeah they're just all smoking weed
and watching watching JK news
wait was it good was it good you should
do a reaction video hi and then just
keep doing it oh ho the reaction it's
like I put two mirrors yeah next to each
other and then you see a portal into
affinity or like when you get really
high and you keep falling down the same
paranoia rabbit hole right I like that
what am i watching you what am i doing
and there's like just like that yeah do
you get a high a lot do I get on high
should be the question how often and I'm
am I not high would be you high
right now yeah I came prepared for a
different show like I said I did my
homework I've every game I should be pre
I for this but you know okay
[ __ ] up this is nice cell never been
to Jamaica so we talked about like Kona
fans we're talking about news and stuff
each other's lives what's up you got a
kid yeah we're trying to get to know you
so usually on the other takes we have
like a random news articles that we go
based off and we try to just comment on
but then the off-the-record we talk
about anything it could lead to anything
can lead to peoples of what's your
five-year plan or like what do you want
any goals you want to cover your plan
oh maybe like 5 10 years older I think
that's the best plan ever I don't know
what people always ask me about like a
five-year plan I always tell them I
don't know [ __ ] man they still ask you
about that yeah Donnie shows me that
sounds like a big yeah what's your
five-year plan it's like I'm like 45
years old I pretty much live
I'm not forty-five years old does that
5-year plan I don't things are put where
is it I don't know [ __ ] happens way
quicker than five years now if I be this
happens in like two years now maybe if
you're 20 it makes sense yeah a lot of
[ __ ] can go down in your 20s what are
you trying to do I go to grad school
yeah you're trying to get married try to
dog you do a lot of your life moves
maybe and if by the time you get into
your 30s it's like five-pound oshit
what's my 20-year plan dude just about
to have that question with their kid I
know he's 11 now 7 more years dude do
you have any kids
not that I own I guess we I guess I'm
legally responsible for them wait really
responsible for yeah okay I don't have
to like be responsible for them like the
day-to-day okay I don't take him to
daycare because I don't ever see him
that's like the best yeah okay I also
don't know where this dream I don't know
where they are if they existent but
theoretically I would be responsible for
them being that they are my spawn yeah
and that's how the government works
you scan to me
Isaac's voice - yeah yeah it is
I heard it eleven-year-old I heard that
[ __ ] on a snapchat gets deeper
snapchat on his story yeah Casey was
like I think one of the cat's caught a
lizard and then I showed you and then he
pans to Isaac and then Isaac like y'all
got a lizard like what the [ __ ] who this
man you know the other day I was texting
you right after you texted me two about
that cuz he ended up I ended up sneezing
what was it I already forgot but she
ended up saying bless you or something
it was somewhere else and I asked Casey
like who was that
bless your tip is gonna be a man I know
any news coming in ah it's gonna be
little weights how's that make you feel
weird cuz I forget that all this time
like I don't know I think it's kind of
weird cuz you don't really realize all
this time has passed you forget that
boys become men I still see him as a
baby like still the same little baby
that would like feed out of my boobies
yeah uh wake him up in the morning and
then he's just pitching a tent but he
stole my [ __ ] this is weird
no we're not there yet Oh at least now
that I know what about the day that you
catch him in the room with his
girlfriend weird open door policy right
yeah this is a five-year plan that's a
five-year plan is I mean what am i you
would take us I am ready I ready wait
for what like lucina's boner he does get
a boy yeah kids could get boners at 1
yeah he'll get a boner
well change his diaper well I was born
with a boner could Ibiza Bryce that's
why the labor took so long just enough
right there big plug changing his diaper
and then uh she had to point it out she
was like she has a bow doesn't why I
came we looked it was just like this
little like no you got the huge enough
all right finest huge is a huge sorry no
I was huge big huge nub yeah we're likes
she was crazy yeah and I pressed it you
were proud that moment you pressed it
like a button oh that's kind of proud I
was kind of proud of that like he's he's
feeling the testosterone you know
there's a test right there man that's
cool to do his veins it's a man but yeah
yeah and I pressed it and it was hard I
was like oh [ __ ] okay he's really
serious about this
that don't lie that is that is a human
lie detector right points one direction
to the truth yeah that's what those are
Congrats on that by the way yeah you
killed it no I don't know I'm gonna do
like hopefully I mean I could talk on my
[ __ ] now and just be like now I'm gonna
be a not a cool mom cuz I'm not gonna be
a cool mom but oh I know I don't want to
say cool mom I picture the mom and
[ __ ] Mean Girls exactly where they
are drink drink it in the basement
everyone's had that no you guys just
[ __ ] dick down here I'm down with it
I love it I'm not gonna be their friend
like that but um yeah I don't know I'm
gonna think every girl that he brings of
him you look [ __ ] really you're gonna
be one of those I don't know I have no
idea I hope I'm not but I might be I
might just be jealous I'm like I want
all your loves like just me I just don't
want to develop a relationship with any
of my friends of my kids friends but
what if they're fine relations you were
talking about cuz you know like when
you're young and they have a [ __ ]
girlfriend or whatever Kayla or boy
don't they're gonna [ __ ] last you
know what the whole point so I can move
on you little [ __ ] like you're gonna get
to it ah that's [ __ ] he's a war man
as soon as they walk in the door they're
already dead what if you like your kids
friends more than your kid I can see
that happening could you're like oh man
you're so fun and my kids so [ __ ]
boring I don't think your kids ever
gonna be boring dude
Oh his kids are gonna be boring as [ __ ]
this good wine yeah because he's so wild
his kids are gonna be like the centered
calm ones cuz they're like come on let
me be the parent here Oh that'd be crazy
if your kid tries to parent you I
wouldn't be surprised remember uh Bart
needs you said that you when you went to
Boy Scouts the Boy Scout leader the
troop leader hit he didn't like his own
kids cuz they're born as [ __ ] and they
like you guys more yeah yeah that's
probably what might happen I think I
liked hanging out with us because he had
a Boy Scout leader he had a upstairs den
in his house that we all hang out that
he had a pool table and he was one of
those dudes that always wore jeans and
never had a shirt on and then he always
had the calendar of naked chicks wait
that sounds
suspect around boys how good is the
venue we wanna like I know break into
this now but you guys never played that
game where you're [ __ ] Scalia would
turn you around and motorboat your
[ __ ] just an elaborate thing just to
get that off your chest here I mean no
no we all we all hung out there all the
time but then I guess like a lot no I
would engage in like a lot of like
wrestling just shooting pool and like
talking about God [ __ ] did he teach you
how to hold this day bart's like I wanna
shoot pool and he grabs our dicks like
that's about it well you just said
downstairs upstairs upstairs Danny
Miguel why don't I hear dance you gotta
get in your house you're already
starting off okay that's great come to
the den it's a like it anyone calls a
room at Danny's like you know what
losing tens animals predators I call
that a dead honor the funny thing is
this is what you say you say you go when
he tells me these stories he goes see
when you say it it sounds crazy I was
like no when everybody says the story it
sounds great your Scoutmaster was
shirtless in jeans with naked girls on
the wall yeah in the videos American
that's it he's fat yeah you gotta are
view with the sink in it
I'm keeping waiting for the finger-like
redeem this support worthy Joyce no
there depends okay
bet they dancing it again it was like it
was like a white guy army vet with the
Filipino wife and I think he just wanted
to do like guy show with a bunch of
other guys okay well like future future
men and then did he ever take some of
the other kids away from you guys and
they came back because his favorite ones
I actually recently came across an
article saying that you know the whole
Catholic thing where they were like the
priests were molesting the boys and the
church knew about it and they hit it
yeah same shit's happening with the Boy
Scouts oh wait
that's news right same thing with the
Catholic Church I mean that was recently
I mean I don't know why never thought
voice cuts would be doing that [ __ ]
either anywhere you get a lot of boys in
here with hands you Scout masters in
there above never touched me
that's don't well maybe just because you
were just the untouched one yeah are you
gonna be like David and be all jealous I
didn't touch it yeah he'll be bad
jealous dude I don't think he touched
anybody but I wouldn't know I wasn't
keeping my house for those things that
back in those days it's funny when you
like look back and there's always the
cool guy you're like that guy's so cool
and then you think later you're like oh
that guy was actually a [ __ ] loser
yeah yes yeah they needed like kids to
look up to them cuz they just sucked
that life yeah one of my old Scout
masters his son was like way older so
here's like a former Eagle Scout you
come out and hang out all the time and
when I was in fifth grade I thought he
was the coolest guy in the world cuz he
would draw a tribal on napkins all the
time sounds very cool he was pod like a
19 year old the graph for when that
becomes cool sharply drops off not go
anymore 19 but I was 10 so I thought he
was really quits the benefit of being a
Boy Scout like what do you would it
would do you get so Boy Scouts I guess
what's cool about is you learn a bunch
of wilderness skills that's dope you
learn leadership team building cuz
they're like starting at a young age
like you have like these like groups of
like my 5 to 10 and their patrols so you
collect a patrol leader then you have
multiple patrols you have a senior
patrol leader that's in charge of all
and so you kind of learn delegation and
leadership at a really young age he
knows a lot of knots these are not tie
knots life-saving swimming um telling
like poison not from poison ivy that
kind of stuff you take like a bunch of
classes and then there's but then like
when I get [ __ ] [ __ ] up by this
random plant that just you swipe it and
then it just burns he tells me
afterwards he's like all you got to
watch out for that one
I thought everyone knew um I thought it
would new that plan no one [ __ ] up
like all I did I just like brushed up
against it lightly and immediately it
just felt like fire and all you touched
that one didn't you yeah skills right
leaves of three let it be yeah but it's
a lot yeah we learned how to weave
baskets neither work did you get to
shoot did you get to shoot guns and
stuff yeah I shot a rifle archery that
sounds so fun yeah boy does it get you
yeah recruiting tactics
look I'll shoot guns hell with a guy
without a shirt and just jeans all the
time
[Music]
[Music]